my name is Serena I'm a data scientist
at barda's group we're a consulting firm
specialized in everything data and we
operate in the US and Canada personally
I'm a senior consultant on the data
science practice and I work out of our
Toronto office in Canada and today I'm
here to talk to you about improving
liens or credibility with an LP earlier
this year we were approached by a
research group from the government of
Ontario and worked on a project in
collaboration with them so they were
interested in leveraging NLP techniques
to analyze linguistic patterns in the
legislation and extract information that
can be useful to the public so we worked
on a proof of concept based on some
Ontarian laws today I'm gonna go over
the objectives and the motivations
behind this project and I'll give an
overview of the challenges we face in
the space and how we address them in
terms of methodology and then we'll dive
into the proof-of-concept which is based
on the accessibility for Ontarians with
Disabilities Act and its regulation so
in order to understand what we're really
trying to do and what the motivation is
behind the project it's important to
remember what we're working with the
dictionary definition of law is a rule
made by a government that states how
people may or may not behave in society
so it seems that understanding laws is
pretty important for everyone now I
don't know if anyone has ever tried to
read it a lot here have you ever tried
to go over a piece of law it's not
really fun it's not that easy to
understand so what I mean when I say
interpretability what I want to get at
is find a representation of the rules
that you're required to comply with and
make them more accessible and more
understandable so in this context what
we want to do is we want to be able to
extract these rules and obligations from
the text identify the entities that are
responsible for compliance and then
maybe look at things like our day
homogeneous across industry
or can we tell the difference between
public responsibilities and private
responsibility or can we identify parts
that are unclear and can be written
better our first challenge was we did
not have a label set available so we
couldn't we couldn't build a model that
was using a training set
no one has sat down and went over the
laws of Ontario and like annotating them
saying this is the type of information
and we want to extract and that's
relevant so we don't have that which
limits our ability of building models at
least in a supervised kind of way then
we have on top of this we have a few
challenges in terms of how we work with
the text because the text is rich in a
specific way so for example laws are
formatted in a very specific way so
they've got a lot of bullet points and a
lot of references and that actually
breaks a lot of the standard parsing and
tokenization algorithms so that's our
first problem the language that they use
is relatively structured and the
vocabulary is pretty it's relatively
limited but very very specialized and
it's very content specific so the same
word can mean slightly different things
depending on the words are it surrounded
by the context that it's used in so
that's also very important syntactic
complexity is another problem sentences
can be very long and nonlinear it can be
hard to understand exactly who's
involved and what what they're required
to do and then again the very
domain-specific so a domain can be a
geography or an industry so if you take
a law that is if you take them out if
you train a model and do that on a law
that is coming from the UK it will be
hard or not as easy to generalize it to
the US for example
so given this challenges instead of
training a single model we built a
framework for analysis and this combines
some pre trained natural language
processing models and then some
unsupervised machine learning algorithms
the goal that we have is to extract
information that is useful and so we
want to
extractor rules we want to identify the
entity that are responsible for
compliance with this rules and then we
want to look at organizing rules in
homogeneous gross and we'll look at what
I mean by homogeneous verbs a little
later when we get to the use case before
we go any further I want you to have a
quick grammar refresher I'm going to use
some jargon and I just want to make sure
that we're all on the same page so in
grammar the subject of a sentence is the
word or phrase that indicates who or
what is performing the action of the
verb so in the context of law this will
point us at the entities are responsible
for compliance on the other side we have
the object and that's in grammar the
entity that is acted upon by the subject
and in terms of law it's the rule
specification so what is that
the entity is required to do in terms of
technology we used Spacey which is a
Python library it's open source and it
comes with a number of newer models for
several languages including English it's
focused on performance and application
in production which means it has less
functionalities in terms of NLP in terms
of NLP and in terms of compared to other
libraries in the space but it's very
fast and accurate and it comes with a
pipeline of NLP modules that are pre
trained and can be used out of the box
or customized so I want to go over some
of the modules of this NLP pipeline and
why they're relevant to us so it's the
text comes in the first thing we're
gonna do is what I want to tokenize it
we're gonna take it and split it into
smaller pieces depending on the language
that you're working with this can be
pretty simple you eliminate spaces and
punctuation but for example if you have
a contract forum if you have aa wrench
for example you have to make a decision
in terms of do you want to split it at
the apostrophe do you want to consider
it as single token or do you want to
split it in some different way so that
some decision-making involved here
next we're going to want to use a lamb
Atty zur and what the lamb of water
lemma tiser does simply mapping words to
their root or base form so if you have a
verb that is conjugated and you have M
arteries what really matter is not what
the what the token itself looks like but
what the reference from a semantic
standpoint is and so they all map back
to ease to be next we'll do parts of
speech tagging so we'll assign each word
to a part of speech category where a
part of speech is a group of words that
have similar grammatical properties
these are things like verbs and nouns
and adjectives and on the last step that
we're interested in is the dependency
parser the dependency parser determines
the grammatical structure of the
sentence so it builds a trees of
dependencies where it identifies had
words and then words that modify them so
just to look at a quick example if we
load a the English model in Spacey and
pass a simple sentence to it the model
will automatically take it and tokenize
it find the lemma of the words attach
parts of speech tags attached the build
the dependency tree and attach to the
pendency parser tree and then I touches
a Flex of flags there are useful in the
analysis the one that I have up here is
stop words because it will turn it will
be useful later on if you're not
familiar with them a stop word is
essentially a word in a language that is
used so frequently that instead of
adding information actually adds noise
so if we're look at this sentence and we
take out is an a which are two stop
words here we're left with these and
fountains and so you might sound a
little bit like a toddler but you're
still pretty clear and make sense to
understand parts of speech and
dependency parsing it's useful to look
at the tree itself so on the bottom of
the picture you can see the parts of
speech tag here we have some
determinants we have a verb and we have
a noun and then the are
identify the relationships between the
head word which is the verb and then on
one side the subject and on the other
side and attribute and you can see how
the tree doesn't have to follow the
order of the words in the sentence so
said that we can go into the perfect
concept where this use case we used the
accessibility for Ontarians with
Disabilities Act this is a statue and
the regulation that were passed in
Ontario in 2015 and the fine rules and
requirements for accessibility for
people with disabilities and it also
sets out a process for eliminating
barriers so in this context what we're
interested in is burdens a burden is a
requirement or an obligation that
organizations have to comply with so in
the context of accessibility this can be
a physical or an architectural barrier
so your stairs and ramps and all of
these like physical obstacles to
accessibility but it can also be
referring to documentation and training
so we'll split the analysis into three
stages first of all we want to identify
the burden so we want to go over the
text and extract the sentences that are
relevant then we want to identify the
subjects of the sentences so what which
are the entities are responsible for
them and then at the end we'll run some
clustering on the subjects to see if we
can find some regularities and some like
way of explaining what the law is
requiring step one we want to again go
over the sentences in the legislation
and we want to find the ones that
express the rule or a burden for an
organization in this case the fact that
the law has a relatively limited
vocabulary actually works in our favor
so we were able to identify a short list
of verbs that were definitely going to
point us at burdens and these are Schaal
must require and oblige so what our
expectation is if the sentence contains
one of these verbs it's very likely to
be a burden and then we use word not to
expand this group word gnat is a graph
dictionary you have the English language
so it essentially takes words and groups
them together based on their grammatical
properties and their concept are
expressing and then this groups have
connected to each other by semantic
relationships so that can be synonym of
antonyms for example so we take our
initial group of verbs and combine them
with their synonyms and build a
lightweight ontology now ontology is
identify I used to identify entities and
their relationships between between each
other in this case in this case we'll
call it a lightweight ontology because
we were really justifying the burdens
but we could add more types of rules
that we want to identify so we take each
sentence
extract dilemma from the tokens and then
if dilemma is included in our list in
our ontology then we labeled that
sentence as a burden this is a pretty
coarse classification rule so we did
want to know how well we were doing and
so we actually sat down and labeled the
sentences in the text which wasn't very
fun but it wasn't terrible it's not a
very long piece of legislation and it
did allows us to come up with some
performance metric so the first one is
accuracy we want to know overall going
over the sentences what's the proportion
of them that's being correctly labeled
so it doesn't matter whether they were
burdens or not we just want to know if
we pick them right that's 89% and then
we want to know of all the burdens that
we were we have in the text how many of
them were correctly labeled as as
burdens and that's 97% which for a
simple business rule I think it's pretty
good so now we want to identify the
subjects or the burden and so by subject
I mean the grammatical subject so the
entity that performs the action in the
sentence and so we should be able to use
dependency parsing you don't need to
remember all this the Stags just know
that there's a few different
that subjects can be tagged in terms of
dependency tree but before concluding
and this is gonna be easy let's look at
the an example so in this sentence the
subject of the the subject is obligated
organizations that are school boards or
educational or training institutions so
what the dependency tree does it tags
organizations as the subject and that's
correct but it doesn't actually help us
qualify what organizations are required
to keep record of the training and so if
you look at the tree we have that keep
is the main verb and then on one side we
have the object which are the records to
be kept and on the other side it points
at the subject which is the
organization's but then those all these
are the words that are actually are
telling us what the entity is really and
so what we really want is use entire
side of the tree so we're still using
dependency parsing results to identify
the the word the head word of the
subject but then we use breadth-first
search to navigate a dependency tree and
find all the subsets of tokens that are
related to the subject by a parent-child
relationship and that's gonna let us
know what the entire phrase is so now we
have identified who's carrying the
responsibilities for the burdens and we
want to see if we can find if we can
organize them into homogeneous groups
before doing that we're gonna have to
represent the the burdens in in a vector
space so that we can manipulate it with
some algorithm and then we can look at
this see we can find my genius groups at
this point we're still not entirely sure
of what we're looking for but we are
looking for any kind of pattern or
regularity although we had some goals we
wanted to see whether we could tell the
difference between public and private
responsibilities for example so what is
the government and
the government where is agency required
to do what is what responsibilities are
businesses for example or we were
interested in similarities between or
across industries so at this point we
still have substrings
and so we just have words so we need to
first we want to normalize the sound
with the subjects and so we'll do some
we use glamorization to map to a base
form and I will drop the stop words
because we don't want any noise
and then we'll project into a vector
enjoy vector space and before running
the clustering we'll run some
dimensionality reduction so I'm going to
keep this the first step sometimes
normalization is pretty straightforward
and we'll jump into vector
representation so for this step we use
the glove which stands for global
vectors were word representation it's a
it's an award embedding model trained
and published by the Stanford and Opie
group and what it does is it creates a
semantic space so where there are
similar in meaning will also be close to
each other in the back door space and
there's a famous example that you might
have heard of so if you take the vector
for a king and subtract subtract the
vector for men and then sum the vector
for women you get the vector for crane
so that's what we're using
or taking each word in our subjects and
we're projecting it into the glove space
but we still have multiple vectors
representing a single thing which is our
subject so we average over the words in
the subject to get a single
representation for it glove vectors come
in various sizes and even we use the
smallest one which is 50 dimensions but
it's still pretty large for what we're
working with which is a group of about
500 burdens so we run spectrum
embeddings to go down from a higher
dimensional space into a lower
dimensional space spectrum batting
starts from representing points on a
graph so points are close to each other
are connected by an edge
under some fancy math and data points
that are close to each other in the
original space are represented close to
each other into the lower dimensional
space preserving little cone distances
so if we look at the picture we can see
the first two spectral embeddings and it
looks pretty good it has these three
pointed shapes or coming out of the plot
and it's pretty promising considering
we're trying to tell the difference
between the static points so for the
next steps we use k-means so k-means has
the goal of partitioning the data points
into K clusters and it does so by
assigning each data point to the cluster
that has the nearest mean so with that
our goal here is to form groups such
that the variance between within groups
is going to be much lower than the
variance between groups so if we're
taking two data points around the same
group they're going to be very close
very similar to each other
if we're taking two data points from
different groups they're gonna be pretty
different
and if we've done this correctly then
we're going to be able to look at the
average of the clusters or the centroids
and we can use the we can use them as
prototypes for the group so we don't
need to look at every single data point
we can just look at one per group now
there isn't a golden rule for deciding
how many clusters you're going to look
for but we do know that we want this
variability within groups to be low so
we run k-means for several values of k
and every time we measure inertia so
inertia is the sum of square of the
distance for each data point from the
closest mean and so we want this inertia
to be going down as we increase the
number of clusters so the heuristic that
we use is called the album method it's a
relatively popular technique for
deciding how many clusters you're gonna
use and so you can see that as you go
down as you go up in number of clusters
the inertial goes down and we're gonna
pick the number of clusters for which
you
we add complexity to the system and add
another cluster to explain inertia is
gonna have a marginal improvement and so
that's three for us and then looking at
the picture below we can see that those
three pointer shapes effectively
clustered together and represent three
different groups so I already mentioned
that we don't have a specific
expectation for what the group's would
look like but we do know that we want to
look at the centroids
so from now on we're only going to look
at the average of the groups and we're
going to summarize them by looking at
the tf-idf score tf-idf stands for term
frequency inverse document frequency so
we take the frequency of the word in a
document which in our case is a sentence
and we waited by the inverse document
frequency which is proportional to the
number of sentences where the word is
used overall so what happens is for
words that appear in many sentences the
score will go down which makes sense
because we it's less helpful for us to
tell to help us tell the difference
between them so the pictures shows the
average tf-idf for the top words in each
group the number is absolutely random
it's just because of the screen size and
so you can look at more or less but what
seem what's important in this picture is
that the three groups are completely
separated and there's no overlapping in
the distribution of the top tf-idf so
that's good looking into the single
groups so we're looking at the average
tf-idf for the first group for the top
20 words it's a pretty skewed
distribution and we can see that I don't
know if it's readable from far away
probably not so the first three words
the ones that have the highest score
there
transportation service and provider so
about 21% of the burdens that we found
are clustered in this group and they
mostly come to the Muslim come from this
transportation standards section of the
law
there isn't anything here that tells us
whether there's a difference between
public and private responsibility which
makes sense we're not expecting there to
be and conceptually we're not expecting
it to be different between one or the
other so this distribution is a little
less acute it'll be closer to the
uniform distribution most of the woods
here are referring to physical objects
this the top two are surface and ramp
but then we have others like trail and
stair so this is 25 percent of the total
burdens and they're mostly referring to
physical barriers and public spaces so
again there's no difference between
public and private and we don't say why
the last group is a little harder to
read organization is the word that has
the highest score by far in the group
and then there are some words that point
at public figures or the public sector
so there's Minister municipality but
then there's others that are more
ambiguous so director employer person we
can't really tell whether there's a
difference between public public and
private however they're all pointing at
administration compliance and standards
so this is about half of the legislation
so to pull everything back together
we've learned that the difference
between public and private
responsibility isn't very clear we
founded the strong focus on physical
barriers and transportation which make
sounds about how the legislation is
focused on this
and we also found there's a large
proportion dedicated to administration
and standard definitions but we also
found that in this group there's a bit
more ambiguities in terms of where the
responsibility is falling whether it's a
government responsibility or it's a
private responsibility so we started
with without having it label train set
and but we're still able to do a few
things we're able to automate the
extraction of rules we found almost all
the burdens in the text we're able to
extract the subject of the grammar of
the sentence and that allowed us to
identify the entities that were
responsible for complying with this rule
so the entities are affected by the
legislation and then we were able to
organize organized rules into
homogeneous group that allows to
understand what's the focus of the
legislation and even identify parts of
it there are not so clear and need more
clarification so this was a proof of
concept as it's limited in scope and
there's just probably more work that can
be done to further refine the
information that is extracted however it
can be generalized and applied to any
legislation into any context into any
domain and so it's a first step towards
coming up with a representation of laws
that is abstract and can serve the
purpose of improving interpretability
in at least a couple of ways so on one
end we have the ability to extract
information and summarize it so the
rules and obligations are more clear to
those that need to follow it so whether
you're an organization that has a legal
department or you're a regular person
this is going to be helpful to be able
to put things in boxes and understand
where the information is and then on the
on the other hand we have lawmakers
and so this can be useful to identify
parts of the law that are ambiguous and
could be written in a different way or
need to be clarified and so in a way we
have an instrument that can be used for
explain and understand existing
regulation but also find ways to write
better laws that are so that our
lawmakers can use them to write
legislation that it's more accessible
and more understandable for everyone
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think we have time for questions if
there's there are any the question if
just to make sure that everyone hears it
the question is if identifying the
ambiguities was helpful in changing the
legislation not that I'm aware surprise
yeah they have a number of ideas of how
they could use it one of them was to
sort of had two ways so if you're if
you're a user of reading some media
articles about some legislation change
for example it would be useful but it
would be very useful to have this like
abstract representation that allows you
to go from the from the media article to
the legislation itself and which is
really hard to do normally because the
language used is so different so that
want that's one of the uses the other
use possibly if you're the government
and want to know and understand what's
going on in the media conversation
that's also another way to do it they
wanted to they were really exploring how
this this this the ecosystem of the
techniques can be used in terms of
helping pop the public understanding so
there's a lot of research and a lot of
models that are used in terms of in the
legal space but they're generally to
facilitate legal work in terms of
lawyers work this is not at all about
that it's really more about
understanding the patterns and whether
they can be leveraged to find
regularities and so use those
regularities to literally classify this
rules in a way that make more sense
or for example identifying duplicates
burden there are duplicates across
different legislation so if you've
established a bird
in AODA and you're establishing some
other regulation there's no need to
repeat it and so that would make the
legislation more lean okay just to
repeat that can we use the our work to
actually label a training set a label
this sat and then used it as a training
set in the future mm I'm not sure
honestly I think it's pretty small
- it's still pretty small and I wouldn't
I wouldn't go as far as using it as a
training set we did label it manually
but I don't I wouldn't trust myself too
much like I said I think it's not that
easy to read and so a lot of the
sentences were pretty ambiguous it's
like is this a burden really or is it
just like sorry I I saw that one over
there for first
yeah
okay did we experiment with other
methodologies in terms of vector space
and clustering widget I personally like
working week a means a lot because it's
easy to understand and I think a big
part of this was to be understandable so
I didn't want to use anything
particularly complex or hard to
interpret so that's definitely part of
the motivation between behind k-means in
terms of embeddings I think ideally
you'd want to train your own vector word
vectors but in in this case we didn't
have the time or the scope for it and so
I picked glove because it seemed to have
to lead to results that were more
understandable and made more sense so
that happens a lot when you're doing
things like clustering because again
there's no like expected results so a
clustering result is as good as you kind
of like if it makes sense to you then
it's a good clustering so we did the
clustering after dimensionality
reduction did we try and flip it so the
reason why we didn't mention added
reduction was that if you take 500
burdens over 50 dimensions the the space
is very sparse and so you can't really
see a lot of Simone it's very hard to
see similarities so the dimensionality
reduction needs to be before yeah that's
right every day
did I find if did I run this on French
legislation because we're talking about
Canada and the answer is no I did not
but it would be a really interesting
thing to do yeah in terms you know we
didn't have scope for doing that but I
would definitely keep that in mind it's
a good idea yeah is there any open
source material about this yes there is
there's a workshop that I gave at a
different location earlier this year and
there's a notebook for it so I can point
you at that if you're interested for
sure yeah is there any sorry let me
repeat that
is there any standard outcome of this
analysis not really again it's because I
think I wanted to live it more as a
framework for analysis like things that
you a process to follow so that you can
get information out again because you're
not you're looking for you you don't
have a set expectation of what you want
to extract I think that's a better way
of approaching a problem so leave it
open and let the data talk to you if you
do have specific goals and want to
extract specific type of information I
think there's there are different models
and different approaches that can do
that
[Music]
I'm sorry I need to repeat that I'm not
sure I'm understanding the question
completely would this lead to the main
specific text processing we're using
domain you mean legal or
that's a good question I think it's
probably generic enough that you could I
would try and approach a problem in a
different and similar problem in a
different industry with a similar
mindset with a similar sort of process
and then take it from there
I wouldn't I wouldn't say this is
specific to law it was designed with the
problems of law in in mind though for
sure is it specific to Canada where is
it applicable in other geographies I
think it's applicable in other
geographies I've had some conversations
about it I don't know that I can say
anymore but yes I think it's possible
yeah and I don't think its language
specific either okay thank you
[Applause]